joining us from the german institute for
economic research is energy expert
claudia kempfert energy prices are a
concern for both households and for
companies should people be worried
well they should not be worried but it's
an unfair distribution at the moment of
the
additional cost which each whole site
has to pay because a lot of industrial
companies are exempted they don't pay
this fee and tariff and they benefit
also from a further effect which is the
wholesale price the stock exchange price
which is decreasing so at the end the um
this feed in tariff is calculated in a
way that was lowering the wholesale
price the higher the feed in turf so
private households have a double
effect here to say just to pay another
effect um this pulling out of companies
from from the equation from
the way things are usually done
energy-wise is that having a negative
effect as well yeah it has a negative
effect because the number of people who
pay this feed-in tariff are becoming
more and more lower so at the end a
reduced number of people have to pay
this additional fee and this is quite
unfair because a lot of companies
where it makes sense if they have very
high electricity costs if they are in an
international competition it's okay if
they are exempted but right now a lot of
companies are exempted and we have to
ask why and it's no surprise of course
that this is all causing a lot of debate
considering the money that's involved if
we take a look at the numbers last year
over 20 billion euros in funding was
earmarked for renewable energy who
footed that bill
energy-intensive industries paid just a
sliver
the rest of the costs came from other
industries trades and services and a
massive chunk from private households
they forked out a whopping 7.6 billion
euros to fund renewable power last year
is that fair no it's completely unfair i
mean a lot of companies could pay much
more but they should also benefit from
the positive effects because this stock
exchange price a trading price for
electricity is extremely low so the
question is though why do not private
households benefit from it a lot of
companies do benefit and that's also
very unfair a total of 1700 firms
haven't had to pay anything towards
germany's new energy transition
that's got to have a lot of consumers up
in arms wouldn't you say yeah because we
have to look who is
where really makes sense to be exempted
because
a lot of companies have very high energy
costs that's okay but for the others we
have to ask why they got these
exemptions and at the end the private
households have to pay more and that's
not really fair
what would be a fair way then of
divvying up the costs well first of all
we need to reduce the exemptions for the
industrial companies to those who where
it really makes sense on the other hand
we have to see that the feed and tariff
is increasing because the trading price
for electricity is so low and we need a
transparent discussion and a transparent
way to calculate the ho the end consumer
prices and here the price declining
effects play also a role and consumers
should benefit from it and so what sort
of roles should the government be
playing where should the government
be stepping in the government needs to
control these exemptions they need to be
reduced and they have to look for a fair
and consumer price and here the private
households have a unfair increase of
price and this needs to be controlled
briefly your opinion on offshore wind
energy there's a lot more wind to
harness in that respect but the costs
are a heap higher i think double yeah
right now they are double but they will
decline in the future so right now we
have to see that we need offshore wind
energy as well for the energy transition
in germany but the cost will decline and
then it makes sense also to start right
now claudio campo thank you very much
for the analysis thank you